der name dieser killerpilze ist
eigentlich ziemlich harmlos kann die
doris heißen die hefepilze aber sie sind
tödlich und sie treiben gerade ihr
unwesen auf der ganzen welt solchen
zentralen warnen vor diesen killer keim
und tatsächlich die opfer sind diesen
pilzen wehrlos ausgesetzt wegen dieser
pilze mussten bereits ganze
intensivstationen geschlossen werden und
sie sind wirklich ziemlich mysteriös
denn eine untersuchung der pilze sorgte
für ein sehr sehr seltsames ergebnis
woher die killer keime kommen und warum
behörden weltweit so machtlos sind jetzt
in klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen zum ersten mal entdeckt
wurden die hefepilze kann die doris
durch einen abstrich einer japanischen
patienten das war im jahr 2009 und
seitdem sind die pilze tatsächlich nicht
mehr zu stoppen nur wenige zeit später
hatten sich die pilze bereits nach
südkorea kuwait südafrika indien und
auch in die usa ausgebreitet und
forschungsteams weltweit und behörden
können nicht viel mehr als hilflos
zusehen feststeht kann die doris hat es
besonders auf menschen mit schwachem
immunsystem abgesehen die opfer sind
also zum großteil patienten und
patientinnen in krankenhäuser wenn das
immunsystem gesunder menschen schafft es
die pilze abzuwehren schlimmer dagegen
trifft es die ohnehin geschwächten opfer
die todesraten liegen achtung zwischen
50 und 70 prozent doch kann man oft
nicht genau sagen ob die killerpilze den
tod der schwerkranken menschen
tatsächlich verursacht haben oder eben
nur beschleunigt und obwohl uns kann
dieser auch es bereits seit 2009 bekannt
ist sind medizinerinnen und mediziner
weltweit quasi machtlos wenn die killer
keime sind zum einen sehr schwer zu
identifizieren und zum anderen sind sie
resistent gegen fast alle mittel die man
ansonsten gegenkandidat infektionen
einsetzt 2016 schlug die amerikanische
gesundheitsbehörde centers for disease
control and prevention cdc dann alarm
bis dahin gab es bereits sieben fälle in
den usa von denen vier tödlich geendet
war mittlerweile sind 174 infektionen in
zehn us bundesstaat bekannt und in
großbritannien mussten bereits komplett
intensivstationen geschlossen werden
mehr als 200 menschen sind dort an kann
dieser auch es erkrankt einen großen
ausbruch gab es 2015 16
in einem medizinischen zentrum für
herzchirurgie in london im vergangenen
september reagierte dann auch das
robert-koch-institut hier in deutschland
und rief zu erhöhter aufmerksamkeit bei
candida auris fällen auf dass die
hefepilze in deutschland bislang nur in
einzelfällen nachgewiesen wurden liegt
nach einschätzung des
robert-koch-instituts wohl auch daran
dass sich die identifizierung von
candida auris in routine labor schwierig
gestaltete deswegen sei von einer
untererfassung auszugehen
zumindest ein erfolgserlebnis kann die
forscher jedoch im kampf gegen die
killerpilze verkünden und zwar wurde
mittlerweile das erbgut entziffert
doch auch dabei hielt kann dieser auges
überraschung für die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bereit das ist wirklich sensationell zum
einen konnte in keiner pilz probe die
vor 2009 archiviert wurde eine spur des
kindercamps nachgewiesen werden
das ist tatsächlich ein hinweis dauern
zwar ein sehr starker dass diese
hefepilze tatsächlich erst im jahr 2009
entstanden sind kurz bevor die ärzte
diese pilze im ohr der japanischen
patientin das erste mal aufgespürt
hatten bei vielen erregern ist das
anders sie verbreiten sich lange zeit
ohne erkannt zu werden
die große ungelöste frage die über allem
steht woher kommt kann die da aus und
warum bricht diese pilzinfektion gerade
jetzt aus bisher gibt es keine antworten
sondern nur indizien fest steht
jedenfalls pilze sorgen immer wieder für
verheerende solchen beim menschen aber
auch bei unterschiedlichen tieren wie
bienen fröschen oder fledermäusen
überrascht sind forschungsteams weltweit
zudem von einer weiteren erkenntnisse
und das ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt
die gen sequenz zeigt nämlich dass
dieser killerpilze gleich vier mal
unabhängig voneinander geboren worden
sein muss und zwar etwa zeitgleich die
unterschiede der verschiedenen stämme
des pilzes sind einfach zu groß als dass
sie von ein und demselben uhr an stammen
könnten
dieser umstand lässt uns fragen was
genau dafür gesorgt hat dass solche
pilze vor etwa zehn jahren gleich
mehrfach zeitgleich aufgetaucht sind
teams aus mikrobiologen und biologin
hoffen jetzt dass die antwort auf die
frage
gleichzeitig auch hinweise darauf
liefern wird wie man kann dieses stoppen
kann sein bleibt den labors und
medizinischen zentren nur eins übrig
sich besser auf die hefepilze
vorzubereiten datenbanken müssen
aktualisiert werden und medizinisches
fachpersonal muss geschult werden damit
zumindest gewährleistet wird dass die
killerpilze als solche diagnostiziert
werden können ja und jetzt kommt noch
etwas besonderes wenn ihr als
allererstes neues zum thema und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hier bei whatsapp an denn
dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantieren ihr könnt
direkt neben vorschläge machen oder
andere ideen vorschlagen der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
so jetzt haben sich acht übrigens schon
2000 angemeldet und ich habe wirklich
jede nachricht beantwortet aber bitte
nur wichtige nachrichten schreiben und
hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf
klickt ein außerirdisches leben leben
entsteht viel früher als angenommen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran
wir sehen uns auf whatsapp also hören
schreiben und so weit ihr wisst schon
[Musik]